j'arrive à l'aéroport
gillot de nuit avec mon petit bobo qui
dorment dans mes
avec mon petit pont qui dort dans les
bras et je me retrouve donc à faire le
trajet jusqu'à les hauts de saint leu
magnifiques paysages un temps changement
je décide donc de profiter de mon fils
de profiter de ces chats et de ma carte
postale je me voyais déjà partagé avec
mon fils tout ce qui faisait les
origines
c'est à dire cette grand père qui était
l'une des dernières danseuses sur
poteaux de livres ou cette fameuse grand
mère qu'elle des luttes des premières
dans le patronat entend qu'ils fissent
hier dans les années 40 dans la capitale
où ce père merveilleux
un homme au grand coeur qui m'a donné
toute l'attention qu'il était possible
en tant que guide avoir la barre d'un
homme qui m'a éduqué
durant tout ce temps enfin quelques
papiers chaîne a été que otg choyé et
enchantement sur ses pieds j'ai donc
profité de mes maigres économies pour
voler à travers l'île profiter mais
malheureusement en fait des priorités de
la petite rattraper ce qui s'est passé
c'est que j'ai perdu mon pilier la perte
subite est prématuré de vous faire cet
homme s'est laissé complètement démunis
je n'avais plus de moyens de subsistance
plus endroit où se loger avec mon fils
et je connaissais personne et j'étais
dans les eaux petit paradis mais
malheureusement un barrage qui ne
servent à nourrir
j'ai dû commencer à prendre des
décisions gérer étudier la situation et
je me suis dit qu'il fallait que je
trouve un emploi au pouvoir reloger pour
qui c'est moi alors ce qu'il s'est passé
j'ai commencé à regarder un petit peu
les grandes villes de lille et je me
suis dit qu à saint-andré l'a dit la
dynamique faisait qu' il était possible
à une réinsertion professionnelle et à
me loger avec un enfant le sortir de
cette précarité
j'arrive donc à saint-andré j'arrive à
me relever mais malheureusement je ne
suis pas adapté au marché de l'emploi
donc je me retrouve bien
subvenir à nos besoins à subsister grâce
aux minima sociaux
dans ce moment de solitude en fait je me
retrouve dans un moment de désoeuvrement
également dans une précarité vraiment
très grande avec la charge d'un enfant
qui nécessitent des soins des besoins
mais je n'ai pas cessé capacité là je
rencontre le prince charmant
celui que dans toutes les femmes rêvent
vraiment ce prince charmant avec son
cheval blanc malheureusement ils
essayent de percuter mais c'est pas
grave on entend même sur le cheval est
oui d'ailleurs en descendant du cheval
je me retrouve avec deux autres groupes
ont un accord je me retrouve donc mr 25
ans 3 pourront pas d'argent en logements
précaires alors les meubles j'en parle
n'est pas à
on partage tous appelés matelas ya pas
de place donc je me suis dit c'est pas
grave prince charmant un peu brutes mais
leur brut mais malheureusement en fait
le brut se transforme vite en cauchemar
c'est une relation toxique je ne sais
plus quoi faire
ya peu rieti il ya plus de sens je ne
suis plus belle ce type du mois je
n'existe plus des termes violences
psychologiques violences physiques
désespoir solitude honte culpabilité
voilà mon quotidien et en attendant mes
trois enfants grandissent en moi et à
côté de toute cette violence
il fallait que je pense ans je ne savais
vraiment pas quand elle est dans ces
moments là je me suis rappelé que tout
ce que mon père m'a des abris et je vous
disais que tout ce qu'ils avaient fait
que j'étais ici à ce moment là tout ce
qu'ils avaient fait que je me sente si
bien que j'avais vu la réunion comme un
paradis ne méritait pas que je baisse
les bras que j'abandonne ma vie ma
p'tite fabrique avait vraiment
cruellement besoin de moi j'ai décidé de
me relever
mais pour cela j'avais besoin de soutien
j'ai donc commencé quelques recherches
et après quelques temps j'ai trouvé
l'association femmes solidaires
en fait c'est pas mon accueilli mon
protégé monte orienté jeu pouvait enfin
commencer bon
et débarrassé du cheval blanc et
récupérer ma voix par eux mêmes donc ça
a été un travail psychologique pour moi
mais aussi pour mes enfants parce que
malheureusement quand on s'en bat dans
un chemin on embarque toujours ceux qui
sont proches de nous ce qu'on a mis au
monde des enfants au sein de
l'association on peut retrouver un
sentiment de quiétude un équilibre et
être rassurés et moi enfin tu rendu
compte que je n'avais pas d'avoir en
fait ce qui était c'est que la violence
est un fléau et tout le monde cache la
réalité de sa vie on ajoute en bois
surtout pas parler de ce qui te papa on
doit toujours faire comme si tout va
bien et tout ne va pas bien
la vie c'est une expérience ça va avec
des eaux sales avec débat et ses comptes
comme ça qu'on apprend à rebondir donc
je me suis dit voilà je batte contre ce
fléau de la violence et en même temps je
vais être maman et en même temps je vais
être fort donc je continue mon petit
bonhomme de chemin et avec l'association
je prends conscience que je suis capable
de créer des choses et je décide
vu que le marque marché de l'emploi
estime qu'avec mes trois enfants pas de
voiture pas nourrissent bien je ne peux
pas prétendre à un emploi
je peux juste m'inscrire en fait en tant
que demandeur et je ne peux pas je ne
suis pas adapté
je décide donc choisir mon champ
d'action et comment travailler je décide
de me former
je décide de passer mon permis de
conduire avec mes minima sociaux je me
débarrasse de tout ce qui ce qui
m'empêche de voir cette trajectoire avec
l'association je continue à ouvrir au
monde en fait
et à entrevoir la lueur qui se trouve au
bout du tunnel mes enfants vivent ils
rentrent à l'école ils ont leur vie
aussi
donc chacun de notre côté on se
reconstruit à ce moment là en fait
malgré les difficultés à maîtriser en
volant malgré mes difficultés à utiliser
un budget vraiment très mal
malgré mes difficultés à sortir dehors
parce que bien évidemment un problème
n'arrive jamais seul je me retrouve
agoraphobe j'ai peur des gens j'ai peur
du dehors et je sors j'ai pas le choix
les enfants sont dehors pour que j'aille
le chercher
et là je me réveille à un moment donné
avec cette phrase venant d'un prime que
je vois un jour à la télé plus jamais et
dans ce qu'il est dit que nous avons le
devoir et le droit de nous défendre face
à quelque quel que soit le problème nous
avons le droit et le devoir de défendre
nous et ceux dont on habille la vie au
monde en fait
et j'ai trouvé que cette phrase elle
était juste elles étaient vraies donc en
fin de compte j'ai décidé de continuer
mon combat contre la violence et j'ai
décroché mon permis de conduire
je suis moins d'attention barreur sur la
route si vous voyez écartez vous mais
j'ai mon père bien que je vous rassure
et je suis diplômé j'ai réussi à fermer
matinée créateurs à pied les femmes de
l'association garder mes enfants les ont
accompagné à l'école ils ont continué à
vivre
ils m'ont bien moi je vais à peu près
bien parce que là je suis sur scène on
savait très bas
j'ai suivi de formation d'organisation
et de gestion des entreprises
l'eau est atteint
j'ai réussi à obtenir mon spi qui me
permet justement t'installer pont
d'entreprise aujourd'hui je peux
considérer que je suis formé à ré
accéder à l'emploi et bien sûr le chemin
de ses nerfs se termine pas comme ça
grâce à toutes ces démarches et à ce
parcours dans la violence en fait j'ai
eu le privilège de bénéficier d'un
article le 8 mars 2015 pour la journée
de la femme justement sujet à tout ce
qui était les violences est ce que les
papes fonds pour aider
il a avancé à ouvrir les yeux sur tout
ce qui nous entoure en plein de bonnes
ou mauvaises
et puis j'ai ôté aussi conviés au
concours julie bass auxquels j'ai pu
participer pour les porteuses de projets
des jeunes entrepreneurs dans ce jour
d'aujourd'hui on reconnaît ma qualité
pas on reconnaît la chance que j'ai et
la joie d'être mère et moi je suis
capable de vous dire qu'aujourd'hui je
suis heureuse je suis vraiment heureuse
là j'ai vraiment peur d'être sur scène
mais en fait de savoir que je peux venir
aujourd'hui partagée et dire oui j'avais
les moyens
j'avais une famille j'étais vraiment ce
qu'on appelle un cas
la sig de l'aja tiki dire vacances avec
un enfant j'avais encore toute cette
insouciance malheureusement on se laisse
porter par les émotions et je me suis
vite collé à cette image cheval blanc et
je me suis vite retrouvé dans une
situation compliquée je me suis caché et
au moment où j'ai décidé de me laisser
une chance au moment où j'ai décidé de
dire stop
en fait j'ai revécu gérer à kerry mali
et croyez moi que le prince charmant il
habitait pays d'ailleurs et c'est une
réalité donc attaquer des cheveux voulu
partager avec vous une phrase que mon
père au foyer
c'est un homme qui a fait ce que je suis
aujourd'hui il me dit souvent la vie est
un long apprentissage
on en apprendra toujours jusqu'à la fin
alors ne regrette pas ce que tu n'as pas
fait mais regrette ce que tu n'as pas
osé faire enfin parce que vous ne saurez
jamais le résultat
et moi je voulais faire un cadeau
aujourd'hui une phrase que j'ai
constitué avec toute mon expérience pour
mes enfants pour les femmes en devenir
pour beaucoup de peur que je vois chaque
jour hésité à franchir le pas et à se
dire j'existe je ne saurai pas c'est
ayez pas peur de vivre
ne regrettez pas votre ba c -b votre
futur provoqué votre avenir
croyez en vous croyez au meilleur lait
c'est beau une chance aux éditeurs
confiance